when the macbook air was pulled out of
an envelope in 2008
man seemed like this crazy huge idea an
incredibly thin laptop with almost no
storage no dvd drive and an underpowered
processor for two thousand dollars
except that crazy idea wasn't crazy at
all it turned out to be the future of
laptops now almost six years later the
laptop has been copied by nearly every
single windows pc maker yet the error
has still kept up in the competitive
market apple just last week released an
updated version that cost 8.99 that's
the cheapest mac laptop ever
you won't notice the update by looking
at the laptop the only change is that
the intel haswell processor inside is
now slightly faster it's still got the
same 12 hours of battery life on the 13
inch model unmatched trackpad response
and fantastic build quality the 11 inch
version costs 899 dollars but i'm gonna
suggest the 13 inch version for 999
dollars if you need more screen and
keyboard real estate plus it has an sd
card slot my verdict on the air has been
the same for the last three to four
years i've never met a better laptop and
i've met a lot of laptops no really in
my past life i was a laptop reviewer but
now what it seems like the best laptop
in the world has stopped getting better
what comes out of this manila envelope
next is it even a laptop
sort of cozy in here so first let's
start with the evolutionary updates i
want from the macbook air the first is a
better screen
like the retina macbook pros the air
deserves a high definition retina screen
some windows pc makers are even starting
to offer 4k screens on laptops i'd also
like a redesign now that everyone's
copied the look i want something fresh
there are rumors that apple will come
out with an even thinner macbook later
this year with a 12-inch retina screen
i'm also yearning for a darker colored
metal similar to the space gray iphone
but those aren't revolutionary updates
and some say that laptop innovation is
dead as old pcs struggle to keep up with
host pcs tablets and smartphones but i
think they're wrong
laptops are post pcs just in a different
form factor tablets are becoming more
like laptops and laptops are taking
features from tablets
but what i really want to come out of
this envelope is a piece of hardware
that pushes this air and this air closer
together without any resulting
compromise that means a very thin
machine with a touch screen and some
sort of keyboard and other mobile
features
maybe it's gesture control or voice
control
siri you have a promising post pc future
maybe it's cellular connectivity and the
processors we have in our phones maybe
it's getting rid of ports altogether
since we're already starting to work
with everything in the cloud maybe it's
getting rid of these big chunky bricks
with wireless or solar charging that
might all seem crazy but so did the
original air and look how normal that
seems now
okay can somebody let me out of here
ironically there isn't enough air in
here
somebody
no really
anybody